Parliament reveals the winner of the  2017 song of prize for freedom of  thought the award honors individuals  defending human rights and fundamental  freedoms MEP is are looking into a new  entry exit system that will register and  keep data such as name fingerprints and  facial image of non-eu Nationals for 90  days the aim is to speed up border  crossings and improve security  cancers the primary cause of  work-related deaths in the EU lawmakers  are voting on stricter new rules to  protect workers from exposure to harmful  substances every year dozens of new  drugs appear on the market Parliament is  voting in a law to better monitor new  psychoactive substances and impose  criminal penalties MEP s are calling for  EU wide protection for whistleblowers  they want mechanisms in place for people  to disclose their information and  measures against retaliation